Literally every time
I hear about stacks,
I can only think about a stack of
pancakes, chocolate chip, of course.
Or maybe I'm just always
thinking about pancakes?
Not actually sure.
Stacks are also list-based
data structures, so
they have a bit of a different
flair than arrays and linked lists.
The main idea is a stack is like
a stack of objects in real life.
You keep putting elements on top and
you have easy access to remove or
look at the top element.
Even if the pancake on the bottom looks
like it has the most chocolate chips
I can't get to it easily.
I need to make my way through
everything above it to reach it.
I also know that it was the earliest
thing put on the stack,
back when I thought I would
have chocolate chips to spare.